all my favorite
musicians were alcoholics all my
favorite writers were heroin addicts um
all my favorite characters were villains
so
naturally i would grow to be a villain
jay where are you from originally
where'd you grow up um i'm mainly from
chicago i grew up there for most of my
life i spent about 31 years there apart
i grew up right around pilsen
and then i lived in bucktown wicker park
uh i lived in the burbs for just a
little bit uh my mom and my sister live
out in the burbs now
uh
and i like it out there
holy uh i'm 46. yeah you're a little
younger than me but you we grew up in
the same
same world same city
uh tell me about uh your family growing
up you had both your parents
uh
until i was 12 i had both parents and uh
until i was 12 i had uh what i guess
would be considered a model childhood
i i'm not from a
broken home or anything uh they're
middle class uh
nice people very step freddy
i had a gi joe flag
not a lot of people could say that um
but i uh
[Music]
so i kind of take the blame for it i
guess i've i've never felt part of
anything
um
even in
what you
people would consider an unbroken very
nice
home
um
i didn't have a connection to anyone uh
i
it was all
kind of like i was a i was raised kind
of like a pet everything was reward
based like you do one thing you get a
reward you get a treat uh don't uh don't
act up
um and then after um
my old man left when i was 12 during the
divorce i kind of had to become an adult
right away
uh
so i
at no point in time did i ever really
feel like i was a kid which is probably
why
i am such a ch man-child
i
uh i don't like to work i can't keep a
job because i don't handle authority
very well
um
but i
i test well and i get hired easily
because i have a i look good on paper um
i i answer questions correctly i could
be who
the person i'm talking to wants me to be
you're intelligent yeah
uh like i was
you know
double promoted i uh always honor role
student
uh won awards for writing won awards for
math
and uh
was in advanced science placements uh
like
one of the things i'd have to do for fun
as a kid with my old man is we'd play
science games or a tribute pursuit
like i when i
was nine i knew pie to like 30 places
uh
and
whenever i would do something
intelligent
um
my peers like the kids that i was in
school with
uh
i moved around a lot so i didn't i uh
in kindergarten i
uh was primed to be
valedictorian if we never moved i was
going to be
captain of the football team
straight a student
um
i like i was going to be the you know
the frank zappa song bobby brown the
american dream
date raping cheerleaders
you know
all american hot dog boy
and then we moved a lot and every time
we moved i would reinvent myself a
little bit to try and change to
to fit into some kind of category
uh and would it never happened um for
one the harder you try to fit in to a
category the more obvious it is that you
don't belong there
and
uh in third grade and sixth grade we
moved both time those are those are
elemental times where in third grade
it's right when kids are deciding they
could pick on each other uh where they
start singling out differences uh
noticing that we're not all the same and
in sixth grade it's
uh we're everyone's starting to be an
adult and the competition grows
and
if you're taught
harshly to live the golden rule that was
another thing and uh
my
when my parents worked when i was you
know three to five before school started
i was in a religious
uh catholic nur uh
day care facility
christian not catholic but whatever i'm
not
uber religious now so it doesn't matter
what it was then um
but all these things led to uh
treat people the way you want to be
treated but if you do that you're kind
of a pushover
and all it did for me eventually was
making me mean
where
the smarter i got the further into this
i got the more comp competitive i got
the meaner i got
um
and then i grew angry
and that will lead you to doing silly
things like um
and a lot of tv was involved people say
don't blame the tv
um to me was even more books uh i got
into charles bukowski at 13 13 and a
half
the the commercial no one says they want
to be a junkie when they grow up
uh i'm gonna do that just to show them
wrong and like all my favorite
musicians were alcoholics all my
favorite writers were heroin addicts
all my favorite characters were villains
so
naturally i would grow to be a villain
um
and i did for a while and it was weird i
lived a
double life where i'd be
drug dealing
but
in a shakespeare play
i'd be
i i toured the world during lights or
building sets or acting or in a choir at
one point
and while i was singing
in churches in europe i was smuggling
heshish
from country to country um
and i lived in thailand for a few years
and in thailand i worked at a club bar
um
where we claimed money
uh
so we could take
you know stolen money out of rotation
mix it up wash it up put it back out in
the thing through different uh you know
you
blanking the word i blank a lot of words
now
um
um
exchange rates you exchange the money
for different money and exchange it
again and then
uh
you you blur the trail so far that no
one knows where the money came from
anymore um i used to
collect
on loans
uh and
i didn't collect unloans for the money
as much as i uh i wanted to hurt the
person who owed money
um
eventually because i got so mean uh
it you look for a reason
um and
i was provided a reason and an
opportunity to go and hurt people
so i did uh
and you you really
if you get into it you can enjoy it it's
a really fun thing um
and from all that uh
i i
i if you haven't noticed i have a rather
powerful voice
um and i could sound very professional
if i want to
i
was lent to other
uh
criminal activities i committed phone
fraud after i worked telemarketing for a
while
i realized that that's basically a scam
with a business license
so i just committed the same scam
without a business license on burner
phones
uh taking
credit cards through uh
different services and ditching it all
and from
telemarketing i ended up being a pimp
for a few years
um
a girl asked me to drive her once and
gave me some money
uh and then
before i knew it i had three girls
living in a loft with me
um
and it was almost like i i was a pimp
but i worked for them
um where who got the money they kept it
but they provided me with everything i
wanted
um
because that i guess that's how
i kept everyone in line and kept them
loving me is i'm like i'm gonna be here
for you i'm your guy
don't give me your money but you were
supposed to keep the money but you're to
take care of me that see that
in a way
if i have everything i want what does it
matter who has the money
like they felt very good about
themselves they always came back to me
and i got everything i
wanted i mean i had them loving me
they're never mad at me i had it
i was eating i was drinking i'd place
uh
if if i'm being taken care of i don't
who cares what money is i don't money
doesn't mean much to me like i said i
hurt people for
almost nothing because i wanted to uh
what i'd get into is the
the act i enjoyed
doing what i was doing i sti i still
would um and then i guess that brings me
around to uh
the what i'm really into now um
is robo-tripping
and i got the idea from kurt vonnegut
uh welcome to the monkey house where
people who are intelligent or advanced
or athletic
were
handicapped so that everyone was the
same
henry i believe his name was he was
weighted down because he was athletic
and he they put sonic noise and
headphones so he couldn't keep a
straight thought
um which is why when i talk i'm going to
ramble and i'm going to hop back and
forth to different things um
i decided you know like i did i was
happy doing these things but i wasn't
happy
in general and i still didn't feel i
belonged anywhere um
so i robo tripping is when you you uh so
i started robo-tripping and that's when
you dumb yourself
you make you make yourself stupid um
there's a lot of ways to do it i i use
cough syrup if you have a drowsy cough
syrup like a a nyquil
i i call it the uh
what's the normal jingle the uh
this
sneezing yankee stuffy had fever so you
can rest music i call it uh
the coping hating clear my head forever
so i can rest medicine
and
if you just take it by the bottle full
and then
um
you have like a shot of whiskey or so to
make sure the ethanol doesn't
poison your insides you you stay in a
kind of euphoric
clouded state
where
um
maybe
maybe it's like
the narcolepsy where
you're never really there but you're
never not like
i'm well aware that i'm here and i'm
talking to you but um
like you can hear that i can't always
think of the next sentence even though i
have the word i don't have it uh
and and it keeps me happy uh
so i'm always kind of smiling because of
it uh and it's uh
it even kills me um where
like i i write for a an internet show
and i'm a comedian so i i still write a
lot
um
but i don't care anymore
and
uh
the release of that stress makes me very
happy
um
i can't keep a normal job still but i
never could anyway and again i just i
can't deal with authority and now that
i'm old i certainly can't i can't have
some 23 year old tell me to
you know make sure you offer extra ranch
with the fingers today
i got a job at a boba tea place i almost
beat the guy up
what do you think the core of your
your dark
take on the world is is from
uh
again i just think it's in my dark the
reason
it all goes back i never felt i don't
feel i belong here
um
uh
most people who grew up the way i did
for the first 12 years would be happy
um
i wasn't very happy ever uh like when i
think back in my childhood i remember
like few moments
like uh
riding a roller coaster with my old man
i was very happy one time uh
when my mom would pick me up from school
uh
i just kind of remember riding in the
car and feeling like
little bitty moments where like you
you know that
you can feel better than you do
and then it's immediately gone
um
where when i looked around either people
were better at faking it than i am uh
or i was too sensitive as a person i i
never felt like a constant uh
this is what i should be doing or this
is where i belong i just um
i i've i always felt a little outside
and a little lost are you an outcast
i'm very much are you a misfit
um
when i think of misfit i think of the
rudolph cartoon with the dentist elf um
[Laughter]
so
sure i'm a train with square wheels yeah
you're definitely a nihilist right yeah
um they call me the nihilist because uh
and a lot of people don't understand
what that means either nihilist is just
a like a hardcore way to say hypocrite
it's like the belief in nothing not
i don't believe in anything
i believe in nothing
there's a difference there
in the way you word it but like if
you're in a situation and you see
somebody who just innocently got
themselves into a jam
you know it's got
it's it's it's uh 10 degrees outside
blizzard
they got two flat tires because they hit
a bunch of nails on the road
they're in a jam it's dark there's
probably nothing open are you going to
help them out are you just going to [ __ ]
that loser it would depend on the person
in my attitude at the time
for example i was at a bar just a couple
weeks ago and uh
there's a lady in there who
was obviously lying to everyone she said
she got her wallet stolen her phone died
and she had nowhere to go and it was
raining
and
i knew that she was homeless and she had
nowhere to go and it was really cold and
really rainy
uh so i just let it crash on my floor
for a couple days
um
because at the time i was
feeling like i needed to save the
underdog you know i needed to take care
of those that
were also not part of anything
however
there's a character uh holly they call
him hollywood ambassadors
and he was a a rather famous one
um
who i i didn't care for much
uh in passing
and he died and they found him in a
trash can
and i thought that was hilarious
and that could also be because he died
just a few weeks after a friend of mine
who was also a hollywood
boulevard worker and she didn't get
any kind of notice no one mentioned her
she was a great beautiful person
uh
again
maybe and maybe that's
one of the things sometimes with those
kind of people i do feel like i belong
because they don't belong anywhere
either right well you went before we
started this talk you and i were
comparing our take on
a certain uh interview that i did on my
channel and we uh compared our reaction
you've only watched the first two yeah
and my take on this young lady was i'm
an optimist so i believe
all kind of good things are possible and
you watched them and said what
i watched the the first one and
immediately thought she was a liar
um
because maybe we smell our own a little
bit yeah i didn't see that
i just i watched it i'm like there
even
and i i eventually got played for a
sucker oh yeah i was like even in that
mo because a lot of people
who
don't like what they do who feel
separated
they'll they could convince themselves
what they're saying is true in the
minute
like
i i need help
my parents didn't hold me enough and
what i do now is it's a shame and i'm
embarrassed of it i need and they can
even get themselves to cry and they did
they need but
with that particular because there are a
few interviews where i see someone who's
do who believes it while they're talking
to you
who aren't they're not going to change
but that even that one i'm like while
they're talking to him like
this is rhetoric
this is not real this is someone who is
uh who's learned to put a show on
uh or who knows what you want them to
say on camera it's a form of a hustle um
it's not even a hustle it's just it's a
survival skill it's a molded technique
yeah it's a this is what people say in
this position and they say it
um
like i said i
i enjoy being the bad guy if i stopped
uh
dumbing myself down i'd go right back to
being a bad guy um there
and there's certain times like because i
laugh a lot
i like i enjoy humor there's a time in
chicago a lot of people didn't know that
i had kind of a double life
and i was at a bar
and i was making fun of some people i
was in a bad mood
and
a couple other regulars who uh
i wouldn't consider friends but we knew
each other
and they thought i was just the funny
comedian who sometimes gets drunk and
talks game
and i was making fun of a guy who wanted
to fight me
and
i was getting you know finishing my
picture let's go outside and it was
squashed and everyone went away and i
was told how lucky i was
that this big guy walked away because
he's a bad man
and at the time i had a gun tucked in my
pants
like
you're not
worse
so
are you generally happy
are you a happy person i'm generally
laughing i'm i don't know if that
doesn't mean you're happy no but it
means i i i see the humor in things now
like and i'd i'd rather laugh like
even when i was a fighter like my
natural instinct when you hit me is to
laugh
which throws people off so uh
i'm i'm not angry
and i'm laughing
so
to me that's
if that's as good as it gets
for me
that's where i get to yeah it doesn't
seem yeah doesn't seem bad from the
outside world it looks like i'm having a
lot of fun yeah what are you proudest of
in your life
um i'm an eight-time published
playwright it's great uh
i
won fringe festival awards yeah so you
don't do that kind of stuff if you're
too too deep in your darkness and
depression and all that anger
a lot of writing comes from
anger i i don't think i was ever
depressed
in fact um
that's one of the big things i don't
believe
in chemical depression like people say
they have
i've got depression so i can't do things
i actually don't believe that's a thing
because most of the people i know
who say they're depressed have a reason
and if you have a reason it's not a
disease
like if you're a kid who uh couch trips
and doesn't shower uh and you you know
you have the
not on purpose dreadlocks and you're
drunk from the second you wake up and
you're high and you know meth all day
and
you can't get a job and you don't have
an apartment
and you're depressed
you should be you're a failure
failure is depressing
um
if you you're uh
you're coming out of sex work and you
work as a real estate secretary now and
you don't like it because you don't make
the same money and people don't talk to
you as nice and you you can't afford all
the the little luxuries you used to have
and you're you're sad you should be
that's failure failure's depressing
if you're happy and
uh you feel
like you're supposed to be
where you are at that time and you're
singing along to journey on the music in
the middle of vons and you look over
at
the tangerines and you're like these
look like tasty tangerines and if i had
a gun in my pocket i would just blow my
head off right now
that's a different thing
that i believe people can be suicidal by
nature and there's something triggering
that it's character flaw i don't like
calling it depression though because
that's misleading and everyone has it's
like the same thing is when
people said um
uh washing your hands
uh
what do you call that
uh um
we got flipped the light switch
ocd
uh
obsessive compulsive disorder that came
to light and people understood they're
like i wash my hands like 10 times a day
i've got the ocd because
no no you don't
like because it's there are people who
like if they step on a crack they have
to kneel and pray for five minutes that
is oc like
because you want to feel special doesn't
mean
you are special and why would you want
to feel special because you have a
disease
like i don't want to feel like i don't
belong anywhere and i don't want to feel
like i'm like when i'm off of uh when
i'm straight i feel like uh
i used to i thought i had a friend once
in high school because our saying was i
hate myself but i'm better than everyone
else
and i believe that still uh she didn't
and we're not friends anymore
was just a lost little girl who wanted
friends
but i still believe that when uh when i
am not cloudy i
i don't know i haven't met anyone that i
feel can
that i can't outwit that i can't take
advan like
uh take advantage of if i wanted but i i
just
i get bored and then i get angry
um
and i forget where i was going i just i
remember are you angry a lot of the time
uh
when i'm straight all the time i'm
always angry yeah see i'm
i think there's a lot of
underlying anger with a lot of us
me included
and some of us can channel it into
something positive i try to do that
i usually i i recognize that all right
i'm angry at something
and i try to channel channel that into
doing something creative
and if i don't do that then i just get
depressed yeah very quickly i i don't
get to the depressed part i like i
generally don't feel low
um
like the other day it sounds like it
sounds like you're very creative
yeah i'm i'm right
whatever right being a comedian there's
no way to be a comedian comet yeah um
well that's
uh
stage time spotlight is just another
drug yeah
it's it's all for gluttony like um it it
like if i another uh
piece of literature i compare myself to
i'm very much fourth house three
musketeers
uh i
i just want
um
so yeah when i when i have a drink i'm
gonna have 50 drinks
um
if it's wing night
i'm gonna just go through it uh
like i i do all things do early like
when i found out about this
um
i was so go watch one
and so i watched 50 of them
[Music]
what's your biggest addiction
um
life i um
because i don't see myself in anything i
just want to consume
um
so
whatever is in front of me at the moment
is my biggest addition yeah but that
doesn't necessarily have to be something
destructive no and in auto it's not
always something destructive it's not a
lot of my ideas if i if i start writing
maybe i'll write 100 pages maybe two
like and that's constructive and but
that's
my drug of choice at the moment is
writing um
i i mean
i guess there's always a most
destructive addiction
and for me that would probably be
alcohol um
because yeah i don't
need it i don't take it
uh
but if i start i'm not gonna stop until
i pass out
it's just uh
you know once it hits your lips it's so
good
um
way in my twenties was probably sex
uh
i was prettier then i have a good voice
i have good eyes
uh i could talk my way into a lot
um
just
yeah i just i uh
shopping
if i you know if i there's so many
different forms start collecting
something i want all of them you know i
just
uh
yeah i'm a
i'm an ultimate consumer i just i want
things if uh
if it's something i find i like
um
because again if i get all of them maybe
that's what i needed you know like i
don't
there is something missing
and it's been missing
forever
um i've
i
i don't really feel like i uh i think
most of us will go to our graves yeah
never getting what we're missing
maybe
um
and again the more the more i've started
talking to other people the more i and
that's okay can sense i can uh
not a
like a kindred connection but now i've
put myself in circles where everyone's
kind of lost
um
if i worked in the corporate world it'd
be a different kind of loss i mean i
guess
uh
although i'm
a
a total consumer
i still don't feel that as greed
because i feel like there's a an end
point
when i drink i'm gonna drink till i pass
out when i collect i'm to collect till i
have them all
uh
et cetera when i when i'm
uh
tripping i'm gonna trip till i feel good
when i was pimping i
i'm gonna just have what i need
um or what i want even it is beyond
needing
uh because i
but when i feel agreed i feel like
there's a
there's not an end to that
um
and if i thought there wasn't an end to
it i i don't know what i would do
because you can't
complete a task that has no ending
and
that
uh
while i could fathom it it doesn't it
doesn't bring you any kind of uh
solace
like
i want to know that eventually there's a
goal
uh and
i think that i guess is what a lot of
people feel is there's no
goal
and
so why do you know so [ __ ] it
have you been in love before
um i've thought i've been in love before
but then
like my mind will play tricks uh where
i'll talk myself into thinking that
wasn't real or
um
they they were out to get me
um
there's a i mean there's there's only
three i could name them the three people
too uh
and if something didn't happen to end it
it was my like the the first person i
actually and i still believe i love this
person um
they committed suicide while i was away
one weekend
so i got to deal with that
and that was
wonderful
um
because i came back and they weren't
answering i'm like why are they mad at
me and then i discovered
uh the body
um
and then of course i got questioned like
did i do it
and luckily i wasn't even in the state
that weekend so no i didn't do it but
thank you for
asking like
the one person that i thought was with
me the one like that i shared a lot with
that i i
finally thought i had a connection to
like
is in pieces on her couch
and
you're gonna ask me did i do it
um
so
that
that's kind of hard
um
the the last one
uh
read something about me and started
thinking i was a bad person um
which it kind of was
but also you didn't have to read that
like
everything was fine you didn't have to
know that and
everyone's got secrets that's not
grounds for
rejecting you yeah i mean plenty of
plenty of women find guys in prison yeah
or or it could have been but maybe you
should have thought about it like
um
because i i still hear how
like
there's a
she still thinks about you or she hates
you because of this or this i'm like
that was a that was a choice someone
else made man that's uh i had nothing to
do with uh well i guess i did because i
i don't even know if i did the things
she heard about i it just it's so long
ago now but uh
we were together for a long time and
uh
it was one of the few times i felt like
i was part of a community because she
had a lot of friends
i had
no friends
so now i had a lot of friends
and when that ended i had no friend i
actually i still had two friends because
they would call me up to tell me how
much they hated her complaining
and uh
now my oldest friend
uh
is one of her friends that
called me up because she hated her
whining
and it just became like we hey now we've
known each other for 20 years
um and then one in the middle was my
fault um
that's kind of a funny story um it was
and oddly it was the girl i'm most
connected to
mentally
uh we had a very similar dark sense of
humor
uh she was studying be a psychiat
psychologist
and i had considered going into medicine
when i was first in college
and and going into a psychiatry focus
and i decided the best thing i could do
in that field is not pursue it
because i
would want to [ __ ] with certain people
like there's no i know me and then later
i found out that all people who study
psychiatry kind of feel that way so
maybe it would have been a really good
one uh it's too late now because i mean
i guess i could go back and start over
again but
i'm almost 50. i don't want to
i don't even know if about the few
credits i had in medicine even still
count um
but we were going to a party one day
she told me
to keep one dude away from her
because he's
always making
lewd comments or advance he's uh kind of
being a dick when he's drunk
and one time he drove her home
from a party and then pretended he was
too drunk to drive the rest of the way
home
and
tried to stay with her and
all this stuff so i'm mad already
uh we get to the party and he makes a
comment at me
i make a comment back
the waitress is slow with the food so i
just
start pounding drinks
um
and before i know it i'm like you know
what
i'm just gonna hit this guy get it over
with
and i walked up and i turned somebody
and i
put him through a table
and i looked up and the guy meant hits
over there
that's a bad mistake yeah
to make it even worse the guy put
through a table had to drive me home
so we weren't on talking terms after
that
i think she tried to get back with me
about a month later because the the
coffee shop where we had our first date
closed and she called me up to tell me
that
and
capricious youth i went i was only there
once
and hung up the phone and so
those three are gone
um i had a really abusive x after them
and i haven't really dated since then
i've just kind of
uh
i hang out with prostitutes and porn
stars
uh for one i've got a
i got a cane so i've got a degenerative
bone and nerve disease
so
uh
i'm more interested in hanging out and
laughing and chatting and drinking
and partying than i am in
uh
sex anymore
and so if you're a prostitute or a porn
star you get
better than i'm gonna offer you on a you
know for work
so i no longer have
uh like the jealousy thing about dating
someone who's sleeping with other people
um
i'd like you know a little now and again
but my my libido is kind of gone because
of the drugs i'm on and
my leg hurts if we
get into funky positions so
uh
like i
i was getting into it once and i went to
put my leg up on the bed you know put
your leg up so you could drive home uh
and i
herniated my abdomen because i i can't
lift my leg so the energy it took to
pick that leg up hurt so bad that i tore
something here and i bit a little part
of my tongue off
[Laughter]
but that night i set out to ruin sex for
someone and i did
so
so what what regrets do you have
um
i wouldn't say have any the the only
sort of regret i have is the medical
school one um and i've had that since i
turned 40 where i thought if i would
have stayed on the beaten path gone to
med school and the
uh
interned and
psych
i'd be in private practice now paying
off all that debt
and instead
i'm a
comedian with a couple movies under my
belt who can't afford a studio apartment
and
drinks cough syrup to stay stupid
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life uh
the most important lesson in life i
guess is to uh
know that it's
it's
ending uh you don't get to
fix
mistakes which is why i don't regret
them because they all lead to place
you don't get to try again
so if there's something you want to do
now
do that thing
uh
what's the worst that's going to happen
it'll kill you
it's going to happen anyway
all right jay thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem super
interesting thank you
you